next question which animals can feel
love
how would you characterize the
difference in bonding and feelings that
cats and dogs have with each other or
with humans
to me cats seem to have less emotion
um so let's say a couple things that i
think are pretty clear
one that the love thing
starts with um
with maternal love of offspring
that this will be separately evolved in
birds and mammals and possibly other
things
you know you have the potential for it
in something like a crocodile
but any place where parents take care of
offspring you could
i'm not saying they do i'm saying they
could i've just never
never never considered it before well
the one time i raised a crocodile i
wondered if it would develop an
affection for me and it did not
you may i guess all right well this is
awkward and it's about to get
even more awkward um but anyway all i'm
saying is that you've got the potential
for love any place where
um a parent must be devoted enough to
offspring
uh to raise them to adulthood and
crocodiles are possible but i've never
seen any evidence of that emotion but in
birds
you'll see it oh my god all right well
you want to explain it before i put it
up yeah just put it up first uh yeah
once you put it up
so all right this is weird yeah
okay here we have right at the age of i
don't know
uh 24. yeah that's a that's a picture of
me when i was younger but
but they all are and he has his first
born in his mouth
first hatched only head as a matter of
fact i'll just
we'll take it down i'll put it back here
for the moment okay
you gonna explain um no not really
oh no okay well look obviously anybody
who knows anything
about uh crocodile ecology and behavior
knows that in order for a crocodile to
get a proper start in life
um you got reflection you need to tilt
it if you won't be able to see it
um in order for a crocodile to get a
proper start in life
yeah somewhat better the crocodile must
make it from the nest to the
water and the way its mother will
accomplish that is to transport them uh
in its mouth
and so here's the story oh god how did
we end up here
um i was you said
mammals have love it's maternal love
birds have a separate evolution and may
be crocodiles
yeah we have this picture in the next
room if you're going to bring up
crocodiles and love in the same sentence
i did it to myself it's what you're
saying
okay totally did you here's the story
not do this on the main live stream i
would not do this to to anyone who
showed up at youtube why not but
okay uh i was working on barrow colorado
island
in the panama canal barra colorado
island was
a hilltop in the canal zone and when the
canal was filled in 1913-14
it was isolated it became an island and
i think it was frank barber
was a biologist who realized that this
was a fantastic opportunity
to study the ecology of a tropical
habitat because this habitat was about
to become completely isolated we were
going to know exactly when it happened
and so he convinced the smithsonian
which of course this was the canal zone
so the americans had
governance rights over it he
convinced the smithsonian to take over
this island and they built a research
station which exists there to this day
it's the most studied piece of tropical
habitat on earth and it's a marvelous
place
and it has infrastructure that allows
you to live there well so
anyway i lived there actually if you
look at
a book called the tape years morning
bath um by elizabeth reut you will find
a just
one chapter is dedicated to me and my
bat work back when i was just a pup
she calls you you're back in your grad
school day as the maverick scientist
maverick scientist yeah she was she was
playing off brett maverick which
probably you all are too young to even
know what brett maverick is
i actually didn't know that no i don't
know what a brent maverick is either it
was uh
apparently not too young and it was a i
think it was a
wild west thing but anyway um so i was
living there
and the people who live there are all
you know
goofy field rats they're all obsessed
with some organism or other and they're
all cool people it's a really exciting
place to live
some of them were actually obsessed with
field rats when we were there yeah spiny
rats
yeah um but anyway uh
so we all traded natural history stories
oh there's this thing out at the end of
you know barber trail you can go see
and you know anyway so that was just
part of the culture that got a fair
dance
right right right actually none on
they're not fair to launches on
uh bci properly no that's right right no
in fact no vipers no poisonous snakes at
all and
even though the little islands in the
canal do have them and the thought
is that bci is big enough to have
peccaries which stamp out the poisonous
snakes
and so anyway they're no way you said
that it sounded like we're still looking
for the peccaries
like no it's known that they have
peccaries but it's the idea is that the
peccaries are actually the reason
the reason that there are no poisonous
snakes on this island is otherwise much
more diverse than the little islands and
perhaps that they actually
intentionally um kill the snakes so they
are you know pigs are smart and that
they
find poisonous snakes and they kill them
yep okay so
uh it became known uh at the point that
a crocodile
buried a nest full of eggs on the island
where the nest was and so we were all
paying attention to this nest which
didn't look like anything it just looked
like a piece of beach
at this one spot and then one night the
thing happens that happens which is the
little
uh crocodiles are ready to hatch and so
they start beeping
there's this beeping noise that they
make and it's adorable but anyway you
know the beach starts beeping in this
place and everybody's like hey
it sounds like the beach is backing up
it does a lot like that as a matter of
fact anyway
so i was uh you know very into
photography and this was going to be a
once-in-a-lifetime opportunity and
set up my camera and got ready and they
started hatching and the mother was
carrying them to the uh water and she
stopped
and that's how that's what a mama
crocodile looks like she
carries them in her mouth in her mouth
to the water and then they group
somewhere and the mother hangs out with
the babies and so
you can see in certain places if a
mother has a nest full of babies that
have hatched
you know under some overhanging plant
somewhere if you go out there at night
you'll see
a large pair of crocodile eyes and a
bunch of little eyes right
[Music]
it's very cool so cute but anyway she
stopped
picking the babies up from the nest and
we
thought that our photographing her you
were there with some other people
yeah we thought that we had driven her
off and that the babies were gonna die
and so i took one of these eggs which
was not opening and i decided but it was
beeping
yeah i it it was hard to tell what was
beeping i thought this egg was ready to
hatch
yeah it did not hatch and i thought that
we had driven the mother off and
therefore were going to have killed
these crocodiles
so i opened this egg to free it and i
was going to take it to the water and
wish it good luck and when i opened the
egg it was not done developing
which meant its belly was open and there
was a big yolk sac sitting there
and i decided oh [ __ ] now what have i
done and i took the animal and i
made a uh a tub that i put in the
bathtub in
my decrepit i was living i was the last
resident of kodak
uh kodak um dormitory which is one of
the original
you know 1913 structures on the island
anyway you were there
because you preferred it uh in part
because it was more private but it also
had no ac
and so you didn't every time you walked
in you didn't you did
you never you didn't get the climate
control so you slept hotter but you also
didn't constantly lose your acclimation
to the tropical environment which you
were doing your work well then there was
the best part about it which was so
the lab clearing was down near the dock
everything comes in by boat
and so the modern buildings are all down
there kodak was in the old lab clearing
which is a
couple hundred stairs but basically
you're up in
the forest and so you know i love
the forest and going to sleep with the
forest making all of its forest noises
outside your window every night um was
great and it meant that i saw things
when i you know went home in the evening
i
saw cool animals and anyway it was just
a much better way to live and it was
certainly worth living living with
termites which was really the only
downside
but um so i had a bathtub
and i outfitted it for this crocodile
and
decided to see if i could get it to
maturity i got it to the point that it
had absorbed all of its egg sac and had
sutured up and um and it was clearly
ready to go it never developed
anything like affection for me i could
it did not
seem to have that capacity and i decided
it was time it didn't
it was also not hostile um no it was not
hostile it was indifferent to me as far
as i could tell
um but anyway one day i decided it was
time
to set it free um muriel hemingway of
all people happened
the island is a place where celebrities
sometimes come to do little
photo shoots and tropical places and
things anyway she was there for what
reason i don't remember
and you've been like assigned to her be
like you be the biologist who
who doesn't know i think i think what it
was was
um certain people knew i had this
crocodile that i was raising shelley was
her name
um and uh i it was time to take
shelley uh to the water i didn't want to
release her right off of bci because i
didn't know
if i would behaviorally have disrupted
her so i wanted to release her somewhere
where there were no people
and anyway i carried her to the boat
that i was gonna take i
had a panama canal boat license at the
time and i
took shelly to the water in my mouth
just because
i wanted to make it as normal as
possible and you know that's pretty
normal looking
yeah um and uh anyway mariel hemingway
got wind of the fact that we were going
to be releasing a crocodile so
me and mary muriel hemingway and a
couple of my friends
went to an adjacent island and released
shelley and that's all i know
um and it actually made the stride
newsletter oh nice
yeah so the the powers that be its try
were
were okay with all this i don't frankly
remember
how many rules i was breaking you know i
was a long-term resident and i was
trusted so yeah i mean yeah you were
there for like 19 months and so you know
i i was there with you for a couple of
those months but at this point i think i
was in madagascar doing my own research
yeah so um yeah once you're there for a
while
they start giving you a little more
leeway
so anyway i think the moral to this
story is yes that picture
looks almost inexplicable but when you
think about it it's actually got a
perfectly normal explanation
um i guess the part of the i didn't know
some of those details but i knew do most
of them i don't remember how it is that
we ended up with a
poster of it ah my good friend cecile
took that picture and years later
actually
sent us this poster yeah okay
so that's how we ended up with it cool
doubt cecile is watching but if you are
hey
good to see you it's pretty late there
she's in germany true yes
yeah um so we didn't answer the question
i mean we kind of did which animals can
feel love you started then we're on
crocodiles right the question
so so cats versus dogs and um and
love and cats having less emotion so i
would say
the basic substructure of love is about
maternal love that gets broadened into
all kinds of things including romantic
love
and um uh fraternal love and all of
these things and this is indeed the
through line of the
two or three chapters in our book on sex
and gender relationship and parenthood
and childhood
you know love starts as this this mother
baby bond
and then gets bigger and bigger and
bigger until you have such abstractions
as love for country
right and it's basically the the best
approximation of what it is is a
willingness
um to sacrifice on behalf of others as
you would on behalf
of yourself right so mothers have to
sacrifice in on behalf of offspring now
with respect to dogs and cats
realize that there is an asymmetry in
the cat love relationship which probably
accounts for what you're detecting
that does not necessarily exist in the
dog relationship dogs have been with us
for something like 30
000 years i think the longest
domesticate yeah
by far and the reason for that is
because they were our hunting partners
and everything else we've domesticated
has to do with farming which is
only the last 10 000 years or so so
dogs are ancient partners of ours cats
are very new partners i think it's more
like
3000 years or something like that i
don't actually know i know it's less
it's a lot less i don't know but the
point is cats were domesticated
as basically guardians of grain stores
whereas dogs are domesticated as
partners in lots of things
and so the willingness to sacrifice on
behalf of you
is something that is wired into the dog
very deeply
an adult cat doesn't have the same
relationship
with its owner so yes cats are capable
of love but the love
that a mother cat has for her baby cats
means that the wiring is there but the
relationship
between the baby and the mother isn't
you know it is not
necessarily the structure of the
universe that babies should sacrifice
for their mother the mother because the
whole point is
future generations should actually train
them out of that so
but one of the pieces of evidence that
um cats
even as adults when their domestic cats
effectively have a relationship with us
that is akin to
we are their mothers is that in the wild
non-domestic cats
those cats that purr and not all cats
purr but those species of cats that purr
never purr as adults they they lose the
ability and obviously domestic cats
retain their purring
and it seems to be a indication
of sort of imagine a relationship with
with parents are you sure that they lose
it completely as adults even when
injured they don't purr
that is what i it's been a while since
i've gone back to
um to check on that but that is what i
understood to be the case when
i was first thinking about this but
that's probably 10 15 even 20 years ago
at this point yeah
i'd want to go back and actually check
for sure the other thing that i think is
a reliable result
is that cats don't talk to each other
but they do talk to us
which is interesting it suggests that
they you know baby cat
mewing uh sending signals to its mother
about its location and its state
they'll they'll vocalize sometimes if
they're fighting right like you can tell
like two cats when they're well but not
even like two cats when they're play
fighting
you you know it's fine until they start
making guttural vocalizations
uh at which point like someone may be
about to get hurt and yeah our guy
two of our guys do this a fair bit uh
but they don't sit around talking to
each other
whereas they'll talk to us it's not
obvious because you're generally there
when they're talking so you think they
do it all the time but
you can document this you know with
cameras that they don't
damn meow at each other hey guys that
was a clip from our monthly private q a
that you can get access to
at my heather heing's patreon and you
can also get access there to
all of the past paid subscriber content
so please consider joining us there
did you mention that these private q as
are the key
to living a better life and living to
tell the tale i forgot to do that
these private q as are in fact the key
to living a better life and what
living to tell the tale living to tell
the tale
go ahead live to tell the tale join us
there see ya